organizmedia.com
I wish I had a, I don't have a sound board to play some crazy sound, some crazy sound
Woooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooooo
I'm really tired right now. I'm super, super tired. Not just from the plane, but, yeah, a gooner is back.
You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. She's back. Hi. Oh my God. Oh. Oh. That's like, again,
you're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner.
You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner.
You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. You're a little gooner. I'm horrible. I'm terrible.
I know I've been
I've been taking deep breaths this whole time and look I don't have I don't have to cough anymore
My cough is gone people were like oh she couldn't smoke weed at her family's house. That's why your coffee is gone
Welcome back real sis. I must use so badly, but don't leave us ever again. I love you so much
We are quiet literally nothing without you or in chart smiling face with hearts sad face
Are you gay?
Thank you for the five dollars
Oh my god, such a warm welcome. Yay. I can finally stop crying and throwing up
Crying and throwing up. Oh my god. Thank you for the
Oh my god the memberships the five memberships pop in November
Okay, breaths breaths breaths breathing
Thank you to the person who got me the um
The the pack of of monster
I've been enjoying it. This is my first one since I'm back
I couldn't they had a little bit of monster there, but it was like really shitty flavors
It was like one or two flavors or only original and I don't like those
Oh
Yay, thank you Mikey back from the crap family trip
Oh, should I here I'll turn that off so it's not annoying
Okay, don't leave us again. Oh there we go acting so gay. I'm on a miss tip 25 dollars darling
Thank you
Are you acting so gay?
I'm on a miss tip 25 dollars honey
Thank you
Oh my god. Yay. We back from the crap family trip. Yay. Why?
Do you buy the cases on amazon? Yeah, I got it from amazon. Okay. Um, okay
I'm on a miss tip 25 dollars. Sweetie. Thank you. I like all the pet names
What are you gonna do with that weird ass something original tip 50 dollars welcome home emmy. We missed you a lot
Thank you. I missed you too. Oh my god
I'm on a miss tip 25 dollars pookie pookie. Thank you pookie
I'm gay. Why are you acting so gay?
I'm on a miss tip six dollars and 90 cents
I've been watching and rewatching your streams while you were gone
Your endy and laly endurance stream always makes me laugh
Don't ever leave us again, or I will bend you over my knee and spank your little brat you behind
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Did you finish with us? I did not. I missed you so much. I didn't. I didn't. I promise I didn't
I missed you too. Oh my god. Why are you acting so gay?
Oh, you guys are so nice. I was expecting all this.
Oh my goodness. I'm cracking open my own monster to celebrate. Yeah. Miss you. Underscore love
Okay, okay. Are you gay? Fuck. Why are you acting so gay? Thank you.
I'm anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents. God. I missed the sound alert and my little sister too
Obviously, I'm surprised people don't hate the sound alert. They're so it's so stupid
Hold on. I think I'm using the wrong capture for um
Are you using the wrong capture for v2 studio aren't I?
All right, that looks better
Okay
Yeah, I have us I have stuff to talk about I have stuff to talk about so exciting. Okay
Yeah, first of all, thank you for 11 000
I truly I gave you guys that goal of 10 k before I'm before I return
Because I didn't think you'd actually be able to reach it. I was like, let me give them a goal of 10 k
So that way um, are you acting so gay? You know, I can get as high as possible. I'm anonymous to 20 dollars
This week has been tough, but I'm just so happy to see you back
After the stream is going to be fun
We missed you so much sweetheart. Please don't leave us again. Let's have a lot of fun together
We will we will have a lot of fun together
Yeah, I gave you guys a goal of 10 k because I was like they're not going to be able to reach that
But let me just get as close as I can before I come back and you surpassed it
I should have been like 12 k 12 k. I should have said 12 k should have been 15 k
I really didn't think we'd even reach 10 k, but here we are. That's so crazy
I don't know if I'll do it like an actual stream to celebrate. I feel like
Maybe this makes me an asshole, but I feel like I need to have a higher uh
I used to be a higher threshold to have like a stream to celebrate maybe 20 30 tip 20
Takes a huge sniff to breath in that tummy scent to make sure it's real. It's real. It's real
I'm actually here with you. I'm real and I'm here
And I missed you so much
I did underestimate your power. Yeah, and yeah the the
The drawing in the uh audio is gonna be your reward
Slurp slurp slurp
Oh
I mean my beloved orange heart orange heart. Thank you. Thank you. Orange heart
20k yeah, we'll do a celebration stream for 20k. That's when I'll do a celebration stream
I feel like 10k is too low, you know, we reached it too quickly. Are you okay?
But we'll do some sort of big celebration. Maybe I'll bake a cake or something. Anonymous tip $50. Oh, thank you. I missed you, Dill
An ice pick ASMR for 10k new surprise. We met the goal you suffer us. Yeah, I'm surprised
I don't know. It's not that crazy of like an audio to me
Like I was probably gonna make it eventually but just not like for a specific goal
And you know make it on my own time whenever I felt like it but here we are
Will you stir ramen for your 20k celebration stream? Um, not on youtube
Not on youtube
Right, right, right. Let me let me talk about what's what's what happened. Okay. I kind of want to change
the background music first
Because
I feel like we need to spice things up. I can't constantly have like, you know, my bgm
I'm gonna hope that animal crossing music with uh
With rain is gonna be okay
I'm gonna hope that's gonna be okay, and it's not gonna get copyrighted. Let's see
That's too quiet
Is that too loud now
Okay, let me just add a wrong thing
Application audio capture you oh wait, what is that the right one cancel or is it?
I'm put yeah, I think it's application audio capture youtube
Okay, and then this one there
Oh
But then I have to
I'm so bad at this. I'm so bad at streaming. Let me turn that off
Sorry
Are you gay? Oh, thank you. Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents. I never thought I'd be interested in a little sister kink until you came along
Is there something wrong with me? Who cares? I'm glad you are back lil ginger
Little ginger did you just say little ginger? What the fuck?
Excuse me
Time to use that 1960s porno music as a bgm music level
I'm not putting that song on I know what you're talking about
Okay
I'll just have it kind of loud. I hope that's okay
Right, let me talk to you about my vacation
So
Um our little ginger little ginger i'm not a little ginger
I'm blonde
I'm blonde, okay
So, um, right, okay. I gotta talk about it. Uh, I'm so sweaty in here
Um, right
Ginger detected lots of things happened and lots of things didn't happen so
I'm like really afraid of flying right
I'm so afraid of flying that I did tell my mom I can't do it again next year
The other years it's like it's like a recent thing. Um
Um
Amy you are ginger. I'm not fucking ginger. I'm blonde
Let me be in denial. Is it too hot in your room? Maybe you're wearing too many clothes. I'm not
You just want me to take off my clothes. I know what you're trying to do. Um
Right, yeah, I'm getting out my mind is so
Jumbled right now. I'm so tired
So I did I told my mom like this is a recent thing
So gay anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents trying this out. Oh
Thank you for the four dollars. Um
Yeah, this is a recent like phobia I've developed I didn't have it before extra hard being ginger
I'm not coping you're coping
I didn't have it before it's really a recent thing and um
I just like
Just don't write them on a bowing
I think I did write on a bowing
I think I did
I remember reading the safety instructions
And it said like what kind of plane I'm on and I'm like, oh wait a minute
Didn't this plane like get into a crash?
Didn't this didn't this model plane get into a crash before?
And a mad junkie won 23 tipped five dollars. I'm so happy to see our little ginger ale back
Lots of love in me
ginger ale
I'm not ginger ale
Ginger ale is supposed to make your tummy ache feel better, but I'm gonna make it worse
This is my handheld fan. This is not a vibrator
I got a handheld fan for my family. It's actually really nice. I like it
I'm really hot. Okay, sorry
Um, right. Yeah, so I was so scared that I just told my mom. Um
I'm not coming. I'm not coming next year
Um, and she can't make me because I'm an adult
She'll have to fucking drag me onto that plane herself if she wants me to come
So I'm not going on this vacation next year. I will be here with you
I will stay with you. I can't go again. I I seriously can't do it again. I like I can't so um
Boeing is just the sound they make when they bounce off the ground
It wasn't really really like
This stalker has got to be fewing that you you won't be going again next year
I highly doubt you know where I went even if you think you know, you don't know
Even if you think you know, you don't fucking know
You have to be a really really like you have to be in a really really tiny percentage of people to recognize where I went. Okay
Like
I will be very surprised if any of my viewers
Like know where I went. So yeah, um
Um
What was I saying right the flights were all super super like
Bumpy and that like America. I did not go to America
I have to burp again
Sorry, it's because I'm drinking monster. Um
I
Forget what else that's what I'm saying, dude. I'm so like
Okay, I'm turning off this music. I can't handle it. I'm so like scatter range, right?
What was I saying
Are you gay the flights the flights the flights right the flight has a costio tipped four dollars and 20 cents
So we have house alone next year. Yes
Well, my mom doesn't live with me. So we have house alone all the time, but yeah
You definitely went to mars
No, I didn't I I debated showing you more pictures, but I was I don't know
It's like I don't mind if people try to guess where I went. Um, because you know, I'm not there anymore
But like I think other people it kind of um makes them uncomfortable because like
You don't have to worry about people trying to like, you know, guess where I am
I'm not worried about that. I've had such a
I've had way
scarier more scary things happen to me on the internet than someone simply being like, oh my god, she's in this
province or she's in in this state or she's in
In this uh, what's it called in this country, you know, I've had way more scary things happen
So it's like whatever if you want to fucking guess where I am go ahead. I don't care
But anyways, um, like it doesn't affect me. I'm not worried about it, but I went to Uranus. I did
I went in and out of Uranus really fucking fast over and over again. Uh, uh, uh, okay
It is a wild history
But I keep turning on the fan
It's not a vibrator. Okay. Um, right. So the flights were really really
Bumpy like all of them. You deserve a real privacy. I know I do but it like I don't really uh
Like I know I'm safe, you know, so I'm good
Um
Anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents if we have the house alone
That means big brother can make you scream as loud as he wants. We are recreating that scene in andy and leili
Okay, well, we still have we still have neighbors we can't be that loud just more fish in that pictures
You want more fish in that pictures? Maybe I can get you more fish in that pictures
Maybe are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped six dollars and 90 cents. Don't worry. We are already outside of your window knock knock knock knock
You want me to open up for you?
Okay, anyways, um
The plane rides being bumpy is what scares me the most like
Every single time that the plane bumps or you know that feeling when you're on a plane
And you suddenly feel like you're falling a little bit
Or a lot
Depending on what fucking plane you're on
Like I feel like smaller planes have more bumpiness to them, but on the way back. Oh my god on the way on the literally
Like I there's this fucking show that I watched hold on. I don't remember what it was called
But it was a show like completely based off of like, um
plane crashes
Let me find it. It was from like wonder channel. There are spectators. They won't be bothered
Wonder is that it
Wonder channel plane crashes. It was really old. Why are you acting so gay a really old show one tip 10 dollars
Please god more fishnet
I'll get you more fishnet. Yeah wonder channel
Mayday, that's what the show is called mayday. It's on youtube
And um, it's literally just a show about plane crashes
And I've watched a bunch of episodes from there and it scares the shit out of me every single time
It does not make my phobia better at all
Oh
The deadliest plane crash in aviation history that only left like I've watched all of these
Here I'll send the link in the
There you can go get scared with me
Oh, no, did not work. Oh, there it is right. So, um
Every single time the plane like bumped a little bit. I was like, it's fucking over. It's going down. We're going down
The first the first ride I cried a little bit more, but then the second ride I didn't like the way home. I didn't cry as much
I still cried a little bit
I still cried a little bit. I was really scared didn't stop watching them. I haven't watched them for a long time
I just like watched a bunch at once and it made it my fear worse because like
Like
Like when you're on a plane and something's going wrong the pirate the pirates the pilots aren't going to get on the
On the radio on the microphone and be like, all right, everyone on the plane. We are experiencing a severe
engine issues right now
Full body. I don't have a full body fishnet people thought I was wearing full body, but it was just um
It was just a shirt and uh like fishnet tights. It was separate
But yeah, they're not gonna go on the you know on the announcer and be like we are experiencing engine issues right now
Um, yeah, like they don't want people to freak out on the plane, you know
So they feel like they wouldn't tell you that something's going wrong
And that's what was really worrying me because it's like what if all this muffiness is because you know
Something is going wrong on the plane
And I won't know until we start falling out of the sky
From I don't fucking know 40 000 feet in the air, you know, so that's like
That's what really worries me and that's why I hate flying
But I made it alive somehow
I was really scared the second the like the way home because it was so bumpy like we were there was like
A couple hours left of our flight and I was like, please just let me make it
Please just let me make it hold there's only there's only a little bit left, please
Attention everybody we are about to die right they're not gonna get on the announcer until everyone that we're gonna die
They're just gonna leave you wondering what's happening until you're dead
So that's what scares me
And not to mention it's like
it's like really um
It's really suffocating and like claustrophobic because my mom's a cheapskate and she bought my plane ticket for me
So
Like red less she bought her plane tickets. So she obviously is not gonna get anything
Anything fancy we went in economy
If it was up to me, I would have bought like
Something more, you know with more space, but she doesn't care
So yeah, I even tried on the way home. I was like mom just let me like let me pay for like see upgrades is fine
I'll do it. I don't care and she's like nope. You're not paying for it. We're not doing it. You're not doing it
So that fucking sucks
Any percent of every flight is on autopilot only during takeoff and landing is the pilot actually taking control
Well, the pilot was shit at taking off. They took off so shittily
On the way home. I remember feeling like like what's wrong? I wanted to curse at the pilot on the way home. Oh my god
The death berry tip 20 dollars. I wish we could be there with you to help you through it
I know I know
I know
I wish you were there with me too
Oh
Why didn't you upgrade her seat right if you're gonna stock my plane upgrade my seat for me?
I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I don't care
My dad is also lg po. I feel yet. Yeah
Oh, my mom stressed me out too. My mom is like both my mom and my uncle are very
They're in denial about it. So they won't admit it, but they're very like stressed people
Like they have a very stressful aura around them. Like they're constantly stressing about every little thing
And because of that like just being around them like stresses you out too
And that's how my mom is and that's also how my uncle is so
um
The pilot saw your name on the passenger list and went oh, let's make this a bumpy ride just for any
Probably
Anonymous tipped four dollars and twenty cents. You want to join the mile high club at me?
Thank you anonymous
Are you asking me if I want to smoke weed with you?
You're very brave for getting on the plane. Thank you
You are breathing pretty heavily because I'm talking so fast. I know so it's hot in this room. Um
I don't smoke weed. I would never smoke weed. I would okay. That's not true
I would never smoke weed with my rats in the apartment, but I might take edibles
Should we do a streamer 20k stream where I get high?
Oh wait the mile high club is when you plop on the plane. Wait
Wait, really? Wait, I thought that's just where you get high
Wait, I didn't know that's what the mile. Hello. Wait. I thought I thought you when I thought mile high club was like just smoking weed and getting high
Oh my god
Ha ha ha
You're only just now. Yeah
Plopping on the plane sounds so scary and dangerous
Sex on a plane is the mile high club. That's so scary. I would cry
I would cry the whole time. I'd be too scared
Excuse me
Are you gay?
You know
I know can we have the stealthy bathroom story stealthy bathroom story? Oh
You mean like the picture of my my fingers from twitter
Mostly on the toilet
I know I'm not saying I'll smoke weed on the plane. I'm saying for 20k. We might do some fun stuff
I don't know
I usually I don't really do like drugs or anything
Surprisingly
Surprisingly, I'm not on any drugs
I mean, I told you I'm not on any drugs because I don't take you know
Gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tip six dollars and 90 cents. I've been holding for two weeks. So these heavy breaths are getting to me. Welcome back
Every little thing is getting to you. Huh? Do you want more?
I
I'm sorry. I'm sorry
Happy 11k. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I I feel like I'm not really that unhinged. I'm pretty chill
I'm pretty chill
I
On life
Not really
Um, oh, yeah, we have new we have new emotes now, right? Do you like them? I like them. I chose them myself
I think they're really cute. I like them a lot
Okay, right
I need to tell you more stories. I have so many things to talk about. Okay
The edibles by yourself before you tried on stream, I tried them. I've tried edibles before
I feel like you know that meme where it's like these edibles ain't shit and then like, I don't know an hour later
You're like loopy. It's like
The opposite for me. I say that these edibles ain't shit and then
The edibles ain't shit. So I don't know
The worst I've ever felt from an edible was my mom came over to visit me
And I ate up before she came and then I felt like slightly dizzy at the grocery store
And that's all on him is tipped one dollar. So what we get drunk. So what we smoke weed
We just having fun and we don't care who sees so what we go out
That's how it's supposed to be
living young and wild and free
Nice song lyrics
Hi on vitamin b for big bro
I'm high on the fact that I can see you again and I can talk to you again
Why did the background music changed? I turned off the um
Animal crossing music. All right. Sorry. Sorry hand picture story. It's not really a story. There's not much to say. I just like
Since I stayed up, you know
All night I kind of just like sneaked away
I just sneaked away while people were like sleeping and I did it
But like I said, I was
Like it was really quiet, you know, everyone was super quiet and I I you know, I sneaked away and
I didn't I didn't relieve myself
I just just a little
I just a little bit
The diary entries getting more desperate was so good
I'm glad you enjoyed them all the prongs
Just being away from you got to me to be honest
It sucked
Yeah, I was really scared someone would hear me because it was like
It was so quiet everywhere and like my my aunt's bedroom was so close to the bathroom
Really sexy at me
You're supposed to be in in the sex corporal. Why are you being why are you not being sex constantly? Um
Not finishing is more of an achievement when you actually could have but chose not to I don't think so
No, I purposefully not finish a lot
You know, sometimes I don't want the fun to end so soon
But yeah, um, it was really loud. It was like
So I just did a little bit and then I left I took a picture and then I left
It was so loud. It was so loud. I couldn't do it. I couldn't do it. Not with people around. Sorry
They don't know you're streamed. No, they don't some of us were suffering there
With you and they're still suffering
right
My rats are fine. Um
Someone said yeah, fuck. I'm so bad at streaming. How are your rat babies? By the way, my rats are fine
It's really it's really cute because I left because I got two babies
And when I left they were still pretty small
But like literally two weeks later and they've grown so much in so little time. They're like almost adult size now
Oh time passes by so quickly for rats
You're in the comfortable enough with your significant other phase uh that I can fart and burp around you
You mentioned that liking the exposure, but I think you have started to enjoy it. No, I told you I didn't I didn't enjoy it
I told you I didn't enjoy it. I told you I didn't like it. I told you I was scared
I can't do it. I can't do it. I'm scared and I don't like it. I'm scared
Um
Let me drink more
Bro my freaking
My models eyes blink stupidly a lot. I think it's because I'm wearing glasses
So it can't always see when I'm blinking and when I'm not blinking
Maybe it's also because of the ring light
I don't know
Okay, okay
Don't remind me that rats die past. I have to remind you it's the truth of life
I've had
one two
Three I've had three rats die on me so far
In all of my lifetime of owning rats. I've had three die
And uh, you know, I have four now so
I gotta deal with
I think I had three die. Yeah, I gotta deal with four more deaths. Eventually
What flavor monster uh, just
Just uh ultra strawberry dreams
Polisa come through I'm really scared of lasik. I don't think uh, I don't think I'm gonna do that
I'm really really worried that I'm gonna go blind. So yeah, no
Okay
Okay, okay, well I have to burp again
Uh, right
Okay, other stuff I did what did I do? Um, um, um
Here I have something I have stories for you
So one thing I wanted to talk about that was kind of funny was um
I just muted myself was my mom and my aunt kept trying to like awkwardly set me up with guys
It was really weird and awkward like the first time was um
You shouldn't drink energy drinks. It's being linked to a huge rise in young adults pieces of core rectal cancer
I'm here for a good time not for a long time
Oh such a shitty, okay
Just remember emmy they might not be around for all of your life, but to the chaos potatoes you are their whole life
I know I know
That's what matters
Right, so they kept trying to awkwardly set me up with guys and it was really awkward. The first time was um
Do they really not know we're together? No, we have to hide it from them
The first time was um
I went to like this restaurant that had like uh entertainment, you know, like live entertainment
It was like an outdoor restaurant. They had live entertainment there
And I went with my cousin um my
Aunt her boyfriend my mom
And my uncle's wife. So I guess that's also my aunt. I think I think so. I think that's how it works. I don't know
I think so um
and my um
My my aunt's childhood best friend came too, right and her
best friend has like a son
And he's not even my age. He's like
I think she's like 27. I uh, I think he's like 27
Yeah, he's not my age, but anyways, they were like, oh
Gay, why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped one dollar does big bro have to fight someone
Who is going to take my little sister from me? Do I need to leave a little love bite on your neck to mark you as my property?
No, no, no, no, I'm gonna take you for no. It's gonna take me from you. Don't worry
but they were like
Oh, you're your aunt's best friend, you know, she's like really rich, right and she has a son
You know
She has a son and um, they're inviting us over for barbecue after the restaurant
Um, and at first because like other people in my family were going to
So at first I was like, oh, you know, maybe because she also spoke french
So that was cool. I could speak french with her. I spoke french with her a bit. Um
She was really nice and I was like, well, you know, because my cousins were going to that barbecue, too
So I was like, oh, um, you know, maybe
Sure, maybe I'll go after um
And she asked me like, oh, are you coming?
She was she really wanted me to come out and I was like, um, I'm not sure maybe
And we ended up spending a long time at that restaurant. I had like fucking three. What's it called?
What's that? What's that type of?
That was a gross thank you for the two dollars gold mario that was a growth spurt. I had three cocktails
Okay, I felt fucking nothing. It was a shitty ass restaurant. The alcohol was trash
At three cocktails while I was waiting for them to like waiting for all the adults to finish talking
I was so fucking bored. The music was
The music was just okay, I guess I didn't know the songs but the other people did so I couldn't sing along
It was like, you know, um, it wasn't a popular band. It was like a local
local band playing
So, um
Just say you you viewing some prospects to mary already us
But um
Afterwards, you know, I was like, mom, it was like fucking two hours later or maybe more than that
And I was like, mom, can we fucking go like I'm so bored even my cousin and her mom had left already
So I was like, mom like let's go
And she was like, oh, but we have to go to the barbecue afterwards. Don't you want to go to the barbecue? You know, her son is there
And I was like, I don't care anymore
And even even um, you know, the the lady my aunt's best friend was like, oh
ask a tv
You know, there's a lot of young people there. Don't you want to hang out with them? And I was like, no
No, I don't want to hang out with them. So I had to leave by myself with my mom and walk home
Because my aunt refused to leave
So I just walked home after that with my mom
Because my aunt was the one that drove us there. So she had the car and she didn't want to go and then afterwards
After that happened a couple days later
Um, my aunt was doing my nails for me. She did a really good job. She painted them like a nice black color
I like them a lot. They're cute, but my aunt was doing my nails for me and um
My mom was sitting next to me and she was like
She was like talking I think I had asked her about like my aunt's best friend's like life a little bit because like
um, you know
A lot of the people in that town are not really rich. So I was like, oh, you know, how'd you get rich?
Why are you acting so gay? Thank you for the two dollars. I'm on a mistipped one dollar
Would we have a drinking game stream at some point? Oh, that would be fun. What's your favorite song?
I want to have it in my playlist to play whenever you are on top online and I miss you
Um, I go through favorite songs really fast
But I can tell you like some of my favorites here. I can type it in chat
You haven't shown us your nails. I'll show them to you. They're not amazing
They're not amazing because you know, it's my aunt. She's not like a professional or anything
But um, she was doing them. So
Oops, all right
I didn't finish typing. Hold on
I I how do I am I stupid?
Fuck why am I stupid? Okay. Well, there's one of my favorite songs
Um
I'm just looking through my Spotify playlist
Uh, let's go with the last one. Okay
There's a bunch of songs that if you want to check out you can I don't know it. There's no pressure anything. I feel like
Why didn't the last one send? Oh, there we go. I feel like oh, I fucking wrote that wrong. It's just love sick not love six
Sorry, I'm typing kind of quick there
You don't have to I feel like I don't know I feel like
Like I don't have a
You know
You know, I don't have the most interesting
music preference. I kind of just listen to whatever
so
You know, it's not like that interesting for people, but it's okay. Um
Right the second time I my aunt was doing my nails and I was talking to to my mom about like my aunt's best friend
And she was just telling me like her story about like, I know she married a
She she married a lawyer
She married a lawyer and then that lawyer divorced her and so she had she got a bunch of money from the divorce and you know
I forgot what she said her son did. I don't know but she was like, you know, her son's also rich
Do you want to see him?
And I was like, um, I don't know not really but then they fucking stalked her on Facebook and they found pictures of her son
And they kept saying like, oh, he's cute. He's cute, right?
And then my aunt showed me a picture
And I was like
You could do what I see does and post the songs on twitter tree
I know but I like I don't want to because I feel like it's not interesting, you know
like
I don't know and I don't think people would be interested so I don't do it
But this feels like when your girlfriend tells you a story about her ex-partners. I think it's funny
It's not my ex. I never even met this dude, but um
She showed me a picture
Obviously he's not watching so I can say that but I so I can say this but I laughed at his picture and I was like, what the fuck is this?
What the fuck is this?
And then I showed my mom and my mom was like, oh, he's so cute
He's so cute and handsome and I was like, um, I don't really like his beard and my mom was like, huh?
He has a beard what?
And I I was like, well, what do you mean what and she's like, oh, sorry. I'm not wearing my glasses right now
I can't really see
And I was like, mom you're calling him cute and handsome, but you can't even see what he fucking looks like
He can't even see what he looks like what do you mean? He's cute
like
Come on mom you can't pressure me like this and not even know what this dude looks like
And then the third time was just some random kid came over
To my grandparents house and my mom was like
You want to see him?
We can walk by real quick. We can just walk by
So you can take a look at him
She's never done this before either. I don't know why she
She was so adamant
She has dollar sign contacts on trill trill. That's probably it. Yeah
That's definitely it
This is making them sound extra desperate. They were they were weird about it
The blur is absolutely adorable
Um, yes, this blurred format on my phone is so cute. You should you should hook up with him, Amy
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tip three dollars and 33 cents. I'll be sure to check out these songs
You said the same thing about the book and that was fun to read book club when
I haven't finished the book yet. It was really fun to read. It is really good so far
Isn't tempted by big money in my heart? No, of course not
Of course. I'm not tempted by money
I don't care. I have my big brother. I don't care about anyone else
She was gonna sell me off
Except I don't think I don't think he was even gonna take me because he's like
She told me like oh, you know, he's uh
Since he's rich, she's kind of like a playboy. That's what she told me and I was like well
Why the fuck would would would you try to get me like to be?
You know to like talk to this asshole
I'm so mean. I was really mean about it
Um
Yeah, you spoiled me enough already. I don't care
You
My model keeps lagging because I'm like dunking on this monster. Hold on a second. Let me finish it
Are you gay? Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped one dollar
So I'm guessing that you like your big brothers to have a bit of a baby face if you don't like beards guys who are a bit nerdy and awkward
I
Okay
I'm gonna be honest before
Before I started here. I didn't really like beards
But now that I think about it more
Maybe I don't care that much
If it's you, maybe I don't care as much anymore
But I I I also do like a baby face too
Gamer sub sponsorship
Shit I can't I can't mention monster anymore soon. I mean what gave ourselves what anyways
Um
Right, what was I talking about you're too good for him. I am too good for him the way she described him to me was like so not
Really attractive at all. I don't know what she thought maybe she just thought the money would like tempt me or something
Um
No, you don't have to start shaving. I literally just said if it's you I don't really care
I don't really care
You changed me
You you get you changed me a little bit
um
More stories more stories more stories
I
Can't even grow a beard. That's okay
The only thing I don't like
Sorry
I'll take a beard. I don't care anymore
If it's you, I don't care anymore. But the only thing I don't like
Is if it's like you struggle to grow a beard like it's really really sparse
But you like grow it out anyways
And it's like the the really sparse kind of beard. That's where I'm like, come on
Just just I I'm sorry, but just shave it off. It's okay. I know you might be in denial, but it's okay
It's okay. You don't have to have one
My my cousin is like that he's in denial
Yeah, like wispy peach fuzz, but he's like in denial and he's like no no no I have a beard. I have a beard. It's just growing in
Like you just just just if you have one, you know, let it grow. It's fine
And if you don't have one, that's also fine. But but but don't be in denial about what you have
No, you don't have to shave after this. It's okay. It's okay
So we can't cope but you can about being ginger. Yes. Yes. Why are you so gay?
Raven tipped four dollars and 20 cents shaving is good for australian kisses mouthless face
australian oh, oh australian kisses. Oh, I haven't heard that one before
Okay, um
Other stuff I kind of want to get another drink. Yeah, just let it go. Just let it go
Um, okay
Hey, if you can believe you're blonde I can believe I have a beard
No, I'm not blonde
God these burps are so gross
What if I had a super over-the-top stylized mustache?
Sure whatever
Guys like I mostly just stayed up all day and slept on or sorry the other way around
I stayed up all night and slept all day mostly. That's that's the majority of what I did
um
We did go to like a different. Oh, I have a funny story about that
About how my my great aunt tried to kidnap me. Okay, okay
I'll tell you that because that's a really funny story. But first I'm gonna go like get another drink
Maybe go to the bathroom. We'll see but after that I will I will tell you the story about how my great aunt tried to kidnap me
I'll be right back
Oh
Okay, I think I'm back
I did not record a twitter audio
I know some of you have your sick twisted fantasies where I go do something
Well, I'm gone from stream for a little bit and and then post it on twitter
I know I'm not doing that. I feel like I'm too
I'm too much of a perfectionist to do that. You guys don't know this and I'm sorry if it ruins some of your uh
You know some of your your uh
Your illusion but like I actually
Why are you acting for the one dollar?
Anonymous tipped one dollar
This reminds me so much of how you were begging big bro to let you go to the bathroom and promised an audio for us
That was the cutest thing I've ever seen the way you were so desperate to make big brother happy
Thank you
Oh, did you want me to record me peeing? No, that's not happening again. That's not happening again, but um your mission
I do actually like I record
I record more some most of my twitter audios with a 3dl
Um, and I have to set up stuff
And then afterwards I do I like I do actually treat the audio like I I uh noise
No, I suppress or what it was a cool like I I I remove the background sound
I do fucking
I do some some compression. I do some equalizer. I don't like I I do edit the audio to make it sound cleaner
Like I really don't want to just grab my phone and like record myself with my phone and then post it right after like
I'm too much of a perfectionist to do that
Like I cut out any like, you know pauses and stuff or if I get interrupted like I cut that out like
I put too much effort like I want it to be good, you know noise gate. No, no, I don't
I don't know
noise gate is just for my stream microphone. I think
But like I I I do stuff, you know, do you do multiple takes sometimes? I do and that's when it gets really annoying because I will like
You know, I'll get all
I'll get it everywhere
And then I have to touch
You know my microphone and my keyboard and my mouse afterwards to restart. It's annoying
Um, but yeah, I I really
I really
I want raw uncut audio
Well, most it is mostly uncut. Most of them have been uncut. It's just like treated treated edited
It's just edited to like sound
Like good quality or better quality, you know
Have you peeing? No
I just I am too much of a perfectionist to like have it not be perfect. It's still raw
You know, it's not I haven't faked it or anything
It's just you know
Gooning and high definition high quality
Put that shit on the surround sound audio system in your living room
You know what I mean
So yeah, uh, that's why that's why I don't really want to just like, you know
Grab my phone dork it off stream and then come back here with you
So I do take them very seriously. I got professionals have standards. Okay. Um, like even
Like um, when I before viewer I would um, leave in a lot of like
mistakes in my audio
Because I knew that I could just cut out whatever I wanted when I was editing my own audio, right?
Like I could just you know, I could leave as many mistakes as I want
I I I had a lot of cut out cut off breaths and I I could edit it myself and fix it myself
But now after joining I'm like
The editors don't know what I want. You know, they don't know how I like it
So I've literally changed the way I record here. So that way it's like easier on the editors and they can like
Edit it edit it better the way I want because I've already
Cut it the way I want
I've only started doing that recently. So I'm hoping more recent audios will have a little better quality
So, yeah, um
I take I take gooning very seriously. Okay
Um, but yeah
What was I saying? Oh, yeah, my aunt. Okay, so
I feel like it's very confusing when I say cousin I have three cousins
um
I have two girl cousins and one guy
We can call the girl cousin
Maria um, and then the the second girl cousin
Uh
Natalia, I'm just thinking of the names Maria Natalia and then the guy cousin can be
Anthony
There there's my three cousins, right?
So I went to a different city to with my aunt
My cousin Maria and my mom and we were gonna go visit my
other cousin Natalia
In that city and also, um, my great aunt also lived in that city, right?
Just do one two three and you're going to forget the names. No, I'll get it. I'll get it. I'll get it. I'll get it
Okay, so yeah, I went to a different city to go visit them, right?
And um while we were driving there Maria's
Dad called us so my uncle and he was like, hey, I know you're going to go visit this aunt
Absolutely under no circumstances. Do not let Maria
Like come with you to visit that aunt. It's like don't let
Don't don't bro is trying really hard not to screw
I can't say real names here. Okay. I'm not stupid
And don't say winces. I don't do anything with my cousins. What do you mean?
but anyways, um
Yeah, he called us and he was like do not let Maria
Talk to your aunt under no circumstances and I was like after they ended the call
I was like, why not? Like what's wrong with what's going on here?
and Maria was like
Yeah, so she actually tried to trick us
into like
So basically this aunt is all alone, right? This great aunt is all alone. She's an old lady
Her husband died. She never had any kids
And since she's old she has like health issues and stuff, right? Like she's struggling and
What she tried to do apparently was she tried to trick Maria into coming to that city
And and living with her
By being like, oh
You can have my apartment after I die like you can come to the city and you can go to school here because you know
There's a big nice school here and you can live with me for free
You just have to take care of me and after I die you can have my apartment, right?
That was the deal that she tried to
Yeah, it's the family drama. That was the deal that she tried to strike with with my cousin Maria, right?
She's all my cousins are around my age except for anthony. He's a little older. He's like 30 or something
I don't know, but um, the rest of my cousins are my age, right?
so
You know, they were like, okay
Maybe you know show us some proof that you will actually give Maria your apartment
And she like faked documents. She like faked something as proof to like
You know prove that she's actually gonna give Maria her apartment, right?
And they found out it was fake and they were like fuck this shit
You're just trying to get you know, you're just trying to get this poor girl to take care of you until you fucking die
And you're not gonna give her anything
right
Yeah, she wasn't gonna give her anything
So they were like under no circumstances. Do not let Maria come to that place because we're mad at her
You know, don't don't let them meet. We're mad at her. She doesn't
She doesn't deserve to see her her, you know her. What's it called?
Her niece she doesn't deserve to see her niece if she's gonna be an asshole like that, right?
So um
I was like damn that's fucking crazy. I hope she doesn't do that to me. I hope she doesn't I hope she doesn't do that to me
So, you know, we drop off
We drop off Maria
With you know, my other cousin because they're sisters, right Maria Natalia our sisters
So we drop her off
You know with my cousin that lives in that city and then me and my mom
went to go visit this gradient
Um, why does every family have someone like that? I don't know
Why scan someone after death? I don't know. I don't know. Maybe she had other plans
With that apartment. I don't know but um
It's not even a nice fucking apartment. Like it's
It's bigger than mine, but it's not it's not a nice apartment. Like it's not in a nice building
It it's not high quality. It's like a really really old run-down place
So like who would want it not me
But um, anyways, I get there and you know, she's
nice, I guess
She's nice like
She's really old so like she can't do much but she you know gave us some
Expired chocolate and she talked to us and she asked us, you know, how's blank doing?
How's this person in the family doing? How's this person in the family doing? Um
How is maria doing, you know maria it's such a shame that she rejected my offer
She literally said that she was so pissed about it. She ran to us about it. Um
Um
Does the apartment have a c no it doesn't like it's a really shitty run-down place
um
So like
After we caught up my gradient was like
So emi
you like
You like it here, don't you?
And I was like, oh, yeah, obviously. I'm not gonna be like I fucking hate it here, you know
I fucking hate it. I I fucking hate this place. I'm not gonna say that to my gradient. So I was like, yeah
Yeah, sure. I like it here. It's it's nice or whatever. I don't I don't care. Yeah, and she was like
Why don't you stay here?
Why is my phone getting a call?
I
Okay, why don't you stay here?
And I was like, oh, um
I
and then she's like
If you stay here, you can live with me
You can live with me and when I die, I'll give you my apartment
You know apartments are really expensive in this city
You can have mine and you can stay here with me
And then I was like
I'm okay. I'm okay. Thank you. It's okay. I don't need it and she's like you don't you don't want a free apartment. Are you sure?
You won't have to buy one. You can just have this one
And you can stay here with me
Uh
Obsessive big bro script idea. You cannot trick me with an apartment. I don't want it
Why the fuck are my notifications?
How do I turn notifications off on this phone? I never really use this phone other than streaming because it's an iphone
I don't fucking care
I thought I used iphone to like stream
um
To like stream, um, you know because they have better tracking
So, yeah, um
It's cute when little sis does it it's only cute when I try to kidnap you is all you're saying
Just tell her you're already staying staying with big bro
She would be appalled. I know iphone suck. I don't like them at all
but um
Like she's really old and like the sense that like
She was she like stood up to like fucking go to the next room to the bathroom
And when she came back just from that like little walk from the bathroom to to her living room. She was like
Like she was really out of breath and she had like a whole bag full of medicine on her table
Like you know, she's old and she has a lot of health issues and I felt bad for her but it's like
You you you know, you have um, you have other cousins you can go you can go ask
Sorry, I'm I'm cousins. You have other nieces and nephews that you can go ask
You know, you don't have to ask me like I don't even live here. You know, I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna move here, but you know, you have other you have other people that you can ask
Stay close. Do you like it when I'm close? Oh wrong button
Yeah, I don't know this. I don't know. I don't know this thing. I'm like I've met her like
Every time we come to visit this family, she always calls and asks us to visit her
And every time we're like, uh, yeah, yeah, we'll come and then we don't come we don't come
Calm down with the sound effects. What's up? What am I I'm not playing sound effects
Yeah, sorry granny, I don't want to sacrifice my youth. Yep, I'm not doing it for a shitty apartment
But before that we went to a mall
It was a pretty big mall. It was cool, but I
I don't know how grossed out you are by periods. I hope you're not grossed out by periods because I talk a lot about my period
But um, I was on my period when we went to the mall and like I said, I was
I had really bad cramps. I had so bad like my cramps are so bad that like
painkillers
Oh, thank you for the one dollar
Anonymous took one dollar come closer big bro wants to give you a kiss
Give me a kiss. I'm ready
Right here right on my forehead. Give me a kiss on my forehead. I'm ready
Thank you. Okay, um
So I had taken painkillers before leaving and I still felt like shit and I was gonna vomit on the fucking
I was gonna vomit on in the car and my aunt had to drive slower for me
And then we stopped before before the mall we stopped at a
Monastery and that was kind of cool
It was really big they had nice bathrooms
Nice bathrooms is a is a rarity over there. So I was surprised. Oh my god. That's so gross at the airport
When we first got there, I went to the bathroom and it was so shitty and gross and stinky and they didn't have toilet paper
They didn't have toilet paper and I didn't have toilet paper. So I had to leave the bathroom with my pissy panties
It was gross but um
The monastery we had a nice bathroom and also there was like a lady there and she my mom wanted to buy a bunch of like crosses
Like those hanging crosses for like the the car, you know the car the car crosses
I'm not really religious but my mom kind of is so she bought like a bunch of those
and they like prayed at the
Inside of the the church thing. It was really fancy and big. I kind of just
Period is blood blood tastes like nickels and coins and I'm the greedy little coin garden
Thank you, June
I'll give you some of my my coins
In me the peeler life really did choose you
I feel like I chose a peeler life to be honest. I was never really that much into pee
You can go to another stall. No, it was it was an airport bathroom
Like it was busy like
I'm not gonna just like, you know
No, it was it was busy and I wanted to leave like I wanted to go, you know, I didn't like it there. So, um
Oh, what was I saying, right monastery
I just kind of stood outside on the bench next to a stray dog
And waited for them to to be done because I was like
I don't really care about being here
Yeah, and then we left and I was more tired and nauseous and then we went to the mall
And then at the mall
I was more tired and nauseous and we stayed there for like four fucking hours because it was a really big mall
And oh everyone wanted to shop because we picked up Natalia and she came shopping with us
And um
I mostly just stood outside and sat on the benches outside
And really did nothing because the malls didn't the mall didn't have wi-fi
And it was only like individual stores that had wi-fi and it wasn't all of them. It was like, I don't know
What's the store? It was like the fucking
H&M store had their own h&m wi-fi
And then the fucking zara store had their own zara wi-fi
But not every single store had wi-fi. So it really depended on which store my mom and my cousins went to
That would determine whether or not I had wi-fi to
entertain myself for a couple of minutes, you know, so that fucking sucked
But I did get I did find a a lego flower
um
Set, you know those lego flowers to to make that's really fun. I've never done that before
So I liked that
I I didn't want to use the my data because like my mom would get charged extra because it's like not in canada, you know
So, yeah
Women be shopping
I shopped a little too, but it was really like
It was like the first store we went to I like looked around and I got like a sweater and a shirt
I might be able to show you that. I don't know
Well, it was really cute. I really like
Are you gay? It was a cute shirt. Why are you so gay?
Anonymous tipped one dollar speaking of dogs. Are you planning on wearing that shock collar again?
Be a good girl little ginger and I won't give you a little shock
Little ginger
I'm not gonna fucking wear the shock collar if you're gonna call me a little ginger
roaming gets really expensive too. It does that's why
Later on I did romanos like mom. I can't do this anymore. I'll pay you for the roaming charges. I don't care
You have a great sense of fashion. We love to see it. Maybe maybe maybe I'll show you what I got there
You don't just have tiktoks. You're not gonna watch save to your camera roll. Oh, no, what the fuck?
The lego botanicals. Yeah that
I remember woman's store. I was in a mall had one of those touch screen spotify jukeboxes on the walls
I rick rolled the store and left
Can we do it on stream? I might I might do it. Yeah, I might
Tough talk for a ginger and a shock collar distance
I'm not in a shock collar distance. Oh, one of the one of the jokers came one of the jokers came while I was gone
Oh, fuck I have something embarrassing to say
You're not gonna like it. Oh, you're gonna be so mad at me if I say this
Okay, I have a confession. Hold on
You're gonna be so mad at me. Oh dude, okay
So remember that remember how we had um a vote for what?
Not scientifically possible
I'm about to make it scientifically possible. Remember how we had a vote
In the free chat over what I was going to put on the color tags
You know because we had to we had two chokers slash colors and I was gonna
I was gonna write something on the tags something custom
Um
First testee here just wanted to say I've been enjoying our twitter and patreon vids like supporting your content. Thank you
Thank you. Um
I don't want to say you you're gonna punish me
You're gonna punish me at the end of the stream for this
I
Forgot
Which ones won the voting?
So I'm gonna have to ask again
What what I'm supposed to write on the tags because I forgot which ones won
Can you remind me? I didn't get any tags. Those were separate. I have to get those separate. Um because they're custom
So, um, no, I'm not making new polls. I just want
I just want you to tell me which ones won
if there's
If there's someone here that remembers
which ones won
Can I know
I didn't write it down or anything
You forgot your mantra once too, did I when did I forget it?
That's no big deal
It seems like you're making a little bit of a big deal out of it. I'm sorry
I'm sorry
It's an excuse, okay
I forgot to what the fuck
Is the stream still up? It wasn't on stream. It was just in free chat
I was supposed to get mad about that. I mean, do you really think that badly of your big brother? I don't know
I don't know. I thought I thought you were gonna be disappointed
I remember but I'm not telling how am I supposed to
Tell me so I can write it like so I can get it custom made for the tag
Like challenge pisser. It wasn't that. What was it? Tell me what it was please
Please I'll write it down this time. So I don't forget
I just remember cock princess losing piss princess
It was none of those. Oh my god. You bitches forgot too. Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped one dollar. I'm about to make your behind as red as your blushing face toggle for forgetting
I'm sorry
It was something like Onichan's property and something with Brad I think
One was property of Onichan big brother's property
I remember suggesting cock princess and you put it on the ball
I put the suggestions not that I like
I like big bro's property lost. What?
Okay, hold on
I think no, I don't think it lost. I think it won
property of Onichan
And what was the second one?
brat, okay brat
there
Okay, I wrote it down
So I won't forget it this time
I'm sorry. I forgot
Hey, you know, it's fine that I forgot because I didn't even order them yet. So that's that's fine
Don't I'm not a ginger. Shut up
Hi
God fucking hot as shit
This is this is really uh
It is really convenient to have to have this handheld fan
I know a lot of you have dirty minds and think I'm using something else, but it is just a fan
Oh, okay
What are they well, I was just like there's um
So like
Not a lot of collars on etsy already come with like custom tags
So I was just gonna get the tag separate off of amazon, you know
So that way I can get like cute a cute collar and then um add a custom tag onto it, you know
So that's what I'm gonna do which color came in uh
Uh
I don't think I I don't think I have a picture of it. Let me see if I can find the listing again
Or wait, I have a picture on throne
On throne. Oh, yeah, I should talk about that weird ass surprise throne gift. Oh, yeah, and also I'm gonna um
I'm gonna try to respond to
marshmallows on stream
now
So um
Yeah, I will try to respond to them on stream
Here this is the one that came oops
This one
This is the this is the one that arrived
And we have one more on the way
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped one dollar. I'd have to know which one you wanted to win
Let me peek into your dirty mind and tell big bro what phrase you wanted to be branded fault with
I don't even remember what the options were
You're right. You are not a ginger. You are a mustard ginger mustard. What the fuck is a mustard ginger?
That's just ginger and a different font
Are you when are you gonna pose for us with it once I get the
Custom tag I'll replace. Uh, I'll replace this this part with the tag
Um, yeah
And then I'll take a picture
Geez, I'm embarrassed. Okay
And then the other one that's still in the mail is this one. This one's cute too. I like what this one has a little uh
Little bell on it
I
Don't know. I like brat. I think brat is cute
Some of them that people um suggested said stuff like daddy on them, but I feel like that's
like
I don't know. That's not that's not our thing here. You know, I don't mind saying daddy, but
I prefer I prefer big brother
I
Was it I want to talk about next I forgot already
Are you gay?
Why are you acting so gay? Anonymous tipped four dollars and 20 cents. You're our cute little ginger
Ginger
Daddy is too generic. Yeah, I know I agree
Picture of you with an on in public
I don't like exhibitionism. I don't like doing stuff in public. Why do some that's ic's territory. Yeah, that's also ic's stuff
But like why do so many why do you like public stuff so much?
It's too embarrassing
Merrows thrown
I did want to oh, yeah, someone asked if I'm gonna look at your tributes on stream. No, no
I'm really undecided on what I want to do with that because I feel like gay
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tip three dollars and 33 cents can't wait for the live tentacle inspection will submit after stream
I'm not doing a live tentacle inspection. I feel like that's
It's too private of a thing to like react to on stream
It's really unfortunate that I can't you know send you a private response, but um
I also I don't know what to do about it. I feel like even on twitter like I also want to make um
Public twitter answers to um put it behind memberships
I don't know
I feel like that's a that's a thing between you and me. I don't want gay, you know
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tip one dollar
I can imagine hooking my finger inside the collar and pulling you close to me and saying you belong to big bro
And when you blush adorably, I'll kiss your pouty lips
Geez let me let me talk
Thank you
I would like that too. Okay, um
Could be a bluetooth thing. Hmm
I don't know. I heard yeah, I saw Icy did a collage of her responses, but that's too public
I don't even want anyone else to like see my reaction. You know other than you
So I don't know
Wasn't Strani waiting for that other site this or next month. Yeah
That that got pushed back a little bit
unfortunately
So, um
I'm not sure what to do about it
Do you know if there is a chance you'll ever be able to respond not on the website?
Not using the website
Yeah
So, um, I'm like, uh
I'm conflicted on what to do, you know
It's too why am I getting calls?
It's too personal. It's too intimate to like do it with other people around, you know
That's just how I feel. I don't know
Because I know you want a response
There's gonna be another site. Yeah, there's gonna be fans leave streams eventually
Eventually eventually eventually
Anything you do, I'm okay with it in me. Okay. I'm happy. Just wait on it then
I don't know
You don't have to reply to them all oh to them at all they're supposed to be for your enjoyment not us
I know but you know
I feel bad that I can't
You know, I want to it's okay
Okay
I can't think of anything else twitter space for followers only
But that's still with others around
My fucking twitter followers are like full of people that don't watch me, you know
They're just there to goon at my audios
Which is fine. You can do that. I don't care. I don't care, but like
It's still not gonna be you know, uh between us thing
As long as you see it and know how you make me feel it'll be all right
Okay
Asking you mean not to be parasocial is like asking let's see not to be wet
Nah, I can be chill. I can be I can be a bro toober. I can be your chill bro
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous took ten dollars. We should each leave our own love marks on emmy all 11.3000 of us
That's a lot of marks
We send it out of love just knowing you're watching this more than that. Okay, I'm glad
Okay, I guess I'll I'll just I'll read some marshmallows now. Um
Oh, maybe I should show you because I know not everyone wants to stick around to see me read like, you know
Marshmallows here. Maybe I'll show you our schedule for this week
I'm so happy to be back. You have no fucking clue
I'm so happy. Oh my god
Let me find my fucking schedule save image
All right, because there's something I need to address within the schedule
There's a little change to the schedule. So give me a moment
All right, there's our schedule so
As you can see we got our zatsu today
I might do a gorilla tomorrow. I don't know. It depends how I feel. I feel like I should use that day to like work
I have shit to record, but we'll see. Um, Friday's an ASMR stream Saturday is a collab with the other villager girls
We're gonna is that everyone one two three four
Wait one two
One two three four five and I'm six. Yeah, that's all the girls. Okay
Excuse me. So we're doing uh, we're reading other people's designs. I think that might be on ic's channel
I think so i'll be on ic's channel
um at 4 p.m
Yeah, and then so sunday I have a member's script writing stream. Um
Man, I feel like there's not a lot of stuff here for
My channel on public streams. I don't know
Well, um, what time for gorilla if you do it?
Edt like during the day
Um, so at six there will be a member's script writing stream, but
There will be also a sponsored watch along
I think uh
at eight
Yes at eight. There's a sponsored watch along for um
So like two hours
After the member stream, I'll have to end and switch to a public stream for
The sponsored watch along of of yume plus's uh
Concert yeah, they're concert. They're doing a concert. Well, uh, I think it was called like
Dreams
Oh, man
Oh, man, I feel so bad for forgive
I'm a terrible I'm a terrible I'm a terrible friend
Um
Dreams come true concert. Yeah that one that I just remembered right now by myself
We're doing a sponsored watch along for that too
So I hope to see you there too because I think it'll be really cool. I've never
I've never actually done sponsorships before
um
It was never my thing
To be honest. I always felt like
Like I have a darling straw plushy
Oh, right. We might get plushies one day. I'm not sure. We'll see. I think strawny talked about that
one day
Right yume plus is another company. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah, there there are friends
I've never done sponsorships before I've had people reach out to me for sponsorships
Like on my other channel, but I always felt like I'm happy with like
What like you give me already so I don't want to like
I don't know how to explain it. It's probably not financially responsible
It wasn't financially responsible. I should uh, I should use my platform to make money
But I didn't want to do that ever but this is okay. This is fun
Because it's like supporting our friends. So that's fun. I like that
Speaking of schedule, what do you plan on doing after the stream?
I'll put up a poll later. I'll put up a poll
Okay, my smell of time. I I don't know if I can show you
I don't know if I can show you most of this
Let me just
There's some there's some
Um, okay, I won't show you this one. Um
Two weeks without you, do you know how big my balls are right now?
Do you remember the scene from scary movie one where the guy sprays the main character to the ceiling?
That's nothing compared to what I'll do to you. Wait
What scary movie? What? I don't
scary movie
One spray scene what it what are you talking about?
I
Sprays the main character to the ceiling
What should I search up to get this scene? I don't know
I don't know what should I search up to get that scene?
I
She lacks critical information I do I do
Pretty sure more than half of them are NSFW. Yeah, you don't know I don't know
Oh
But I don't know how to find a sex scene
To see pop
Oh, whoa, I can't show that whoa
We
What happens to the ceiling
What am I at the right? That's the one are you sure?
Nothing they're watching it
What the fuck is this movie the whole house is shaking
What
Wait, what did he just like he literally got like mega skinny
Okay, okay, I see what Jimmy and I see what Jimmy
I mean, please bait for me. I need to hear you nut. Yes. Yes, I will eventually
Um sat to hear can I show this one?
Wait sat to hear you okay. I'll I'll read the start of it and then I'll uh
So that way you know like what you sent in that I'm reading it and but I won't read the whole thing
So sad to see that sad to hear you won't be going on vacay next year and I think
No, it's not no, I don't even know what that is
No
I
Interesting interesting
Bread with big bro
I thought I was gonna be like answering questions or like sharing some funny moments, but it's all just like have sex with me have sex with me
Which is fine, it's cute
um
Share with the class no
It's it's for you to know that I read it. Okay, and then if it's something important I'll share with you
Okay, uh, you saw my mellow my you saw my mellow you even made a tweet
Oh
My
Okay, uh, I missed you so much. I've been replaying your thoughts for the last few days. Oh, I saw some people were replaying my thoughts
That's really cute. I was replaying my thoughts too
I don't know. I just I missed like interacting with you
Um, let me please don't tweet from between two to three. I've got a work meeting and I'll miss whatever you say
Please I'll suck your toes. I think I did tweet from that time
I think I did tweet. I'm sorry. I didn't see it
I don't get notifications for my shrill anymore. I have to go to the site itself. I guess I could probably turn on notifications
Hypothetically, how do I go about surprising gifting you on throne? Oh, right. I wanted to talk about that
Replaying emi's vod does now I knew you from the super baiting
Um someone gifted me the strangest surprise gift now. I don't actually know
How you surprise gift me? Let me let me go on my throne and see I'm sure it's a fun
You know, it's a fun thing to uh do
But I'm not really sure how you do it. Some person someone figured it out. Obviously surprise gifts
Huh
I don't know
Maybe throne sent me the wrong item
Maybe they sent me the wrong item. I feel like it was really random
like little boys shirts
It was like a little it was two little boys shirts about like trucks. It was like, um
One of them said like I'm three year old three years old and I love trucks or something like
Like I
I don't know
I have no clue how you do it
I
Don't know maybe throne sent me the wrong item the dress did fit though
The dress did fit me which is cool. So I guess I have a new dress now. It's um
It's uh, do this do the single mom emi
Does the shirt fit right? Yeah, everyone thinks oh, I want emi to be in a cute three-year-old little boy shirt
What the fuck do you think do you think a three-year-old shirt fits me?
No
I don't know what to do with it. I'm not gonna fucking wear it
Maybe like the the sweater it's a sweater in a shirt. Maybe if I try to squeeze into the shirt, it'll fit me stupidly
It'll look stupid as hell
It'll be really cropped and stuff and I'm never gonna wear it because it's probably gonna be really uncomfortable
The dress is the dress is kind of cute if throne sent me the wrong item then you know
I guess I have all this random shit now
The dress is kind of cute. I I don't see myself
Wearing the dress because it's like
Really revealing. It's like really really revealing. So, um
I don't see myself ever taking a picture in it. Sorry if that's what you wanted the posters are nice though
It's like a one of them was like a picture of a pin-up girl and it said like hoeing ain't easy
And then the other one was like a picture of a bunch of girls asses in a line
I I don't think I can put that one up, but it's nice. I like it
Thank you, I guess
Um
Okay, I read that one
Oh my god, these are all just horny
Would you like an audio of your brother
coking and
tagging on your strap while you
Frick his face
Sure, if you want to send me that sure
This is a random twitter link. Let's see what it's
Says oh, let me just mute. What is this random twitter link that someone sent me?
Oh, okay, it's just a picture a cute picture a cute loving picture. I appreciate that
You're all refreshed in case someone sent. Hi, Amy refling here. We're glad to see you home safe and healthy. Oh, thank you refling. Oh, thank you
Okay, Amy, here's a question for you
If I have 30 apples you buy exactly seven of them on October 9th 2008 adjusting for inflation
How much will it cost to buy a 2001 Honda Civic with at least
250 miles on it given that the weather is cloudy and that you're wearing a black shirt. Show me your work
I couldn't even do fucking sixth grade math. No, I'm not showing anything
We're the dress just for us. What do you mean just for us? What do you mean just for us like in a memory stream? Like I don't know
I I it's too much dude. It's too much. I can't I can't
Amy I'm so ready to dot dot dot. Well, you know exactly what I'm ready for have fun imagining
I will I will
NSFW an exclamation point exclamation point man exclamation point. I want to spoon you so bad. I want to
Oh, wow
Oh
I want that too
Memory stream or a tweet anything to me, but if it's a tweet everyone will see it
Welcome uh on behalf of all the snow put snow berries feeler wasn't the same without its pretty little sister. Oh, thank you
I will become a member just as you in that dress. You don't even know what it looks like
You don't even know what it looks like. It could be a really ugly dress. I mean, it's not ugly, but it's not
It's very simple. Maybe I could even find it. Hold on
I don't know where it was sent from
Maybe on Amazon or something
It was like a strapped
None of these look like it
Maybe on Amazon
But
No, none of these look like it
Okay, well, I can show you a picture of what it kind of looks like
The color is wrong and the texture looks different, but it looks like this kind of
It looks like this dress
But like more green
Why is this widened did I widen that?
Um, she's a little
There it looks like that
Oh, wait, no, I think it's widened because my monitor is fucked up
Why
Why okay, sorry. Um, it looks like that. Yeah
How do I fix the wideness? I'm so sorry lady. How do I
Oh fuck
It looks like that but like, um
More green. This is like a
I don't know what kind of green this is but it's more like a dark green and no, I'm not gonna wear it
Okay, back to marshmallows
You like receiving our roleplay audios is there something specifically you'd like to receive
I do like receiving roleplay audios. I I do really like receiving them. Um
And then someone else said thoughts on fanboy roleplay audio could be interpreted both ways you making the audio
I'm doing the audio. I don't think I'll ever do a fanboy audio just because
Oh, thank you
Anonymous tipped five dollars. We are all asking nicely. I mean we need to see this dress, please
Everyone that's asking doesn't
Lacks every what every single one of you that's asking lacks critical information. So I'm not showing you the dress
Um
Is it regular or see-through? It's not see-through. It's normal. Um, I do like roleplay audios
Is there something specific you'd like to receive?
Um
I don't know. It doesn't have to be like
Sexual it could be just something cute. I like the cute ones like cuddling or something
you know
Or it could be sexual
Just whatever you want to send me or whatever you're comfortable with I just I I appreciate anything you're comfortable with sending. It's okay
Um
Oh, I'm once again asking for confirmation of when your period ended
I'm not an expert at doing this, but I believe the early data is especially important to get right
And this is the one that that's checking my period
Oh, that's the wrong thing. Let me see
What this link is right?
Oh, I miss you too
um
I'm still on birth control
But my period I'm really I'm really fucking bad with birth control, man
I started taking my birth control again
I'm like really irregular with it. I'm gonna fucking die of a blood clot because I'm so bad at taking my birth control
I think I started taking it again
On Monday
No
On Tuesday
No on Monday on Monday. Yeah. No. Yeah on Monday
I don't know if that helps you my period ended like maybe like Friday
Or something Friday or Saturday
So the fifth
There you go. If you want to know
I eat blood clots for breakfast. No, I'm saying like blood clots in my body
Don't you know that like
um
Birth control like raises your um chance of getting blood clots
I would love for you to remind me. Yes
And I already have high blood pressure so like
Yeah
You made it through your flight. Hope you enjoyed sleeping in your own bed again. Absolutely. I did well
I slept on the couch
I slept on my couch bed because I really like I don't know something about sleeping on a on a pullout couch is like really uh
What's it called? It's nostalgic for me
So I slept on my couch
Because I have a pullout couch so I like it
If the pill you're on is one of those once daily pills
You should take one every day make it a habit first thing in the morning unless your doctor tells you to yeah
Why are you acting so gay?
Anonymous tipped one dollar. Did you know that I see how to train rent on her during a gaming stream?
We need to one up the snowberries chug it chug it choo choo
No, I don't want to train
I don't want to train. I just want you. I don't want a whole train
I'm sorry. I can't I can't do that
I don't know if I'll ever play a game with you because I'm already so bad at games like it'll be frustrating to play with me
Couch is the only thing pulling out
Um, can doctors give you birth control knowing your blood pressure situation? Yeah, they can it is one of those once a day pills
I try my best to take it once a day
Sometimes I have to take it twice a day because I forgot the other day
God, I'm gonna fucking die of blood clots. Um
Hope you enjoyed sleeping in your own bed again while I don't have plain anxiety. I do understand having these sorts of fears where
Despite knowing it is irrational. It still fucks you up for me. It's crowds no matter how many
Fuck any more water
You
You're gonna die in me am I actually is it that dangerous? I've been doing it for like a long time. Is that dangerous?
Allow yourself to be carried is that fun though?
I
Don't know on your bathroom mirror so you read the note every day taking care of your health is important
I know I should
I know I actually just got an email saying my birth control got delivered
I get it through the mail. Okay. You made it through your flight. Blah blah. I do understand. Yay
For me, it's crowds no matter how many times you're told that it's irrational
It still weighs on you if you ever need or want to you can tweet about this sort of stuff
Nobody in your community is going to judge you for it. Oh, I actually find it endearing still
I'm glad you were able to make it through the flight. You're strong and better than you think you are in every way
Um
Rest well and take another day if you need to another day or two is nothing
I want to see you but taking that day to make sure you're in the best shape
You can be as infinitely more important because you are infinitely more important. Love you darling
Thank you
I I probably should have taken another day
Because I haven't even finished packing and I slept a lot of the day today and then I did other stuff today
It feels like a teacher's reviewing your homework. Why?
There's there's they're all so wholesome. I'm just I'm just seeing what you said
And also I'm reading I'm trying to read the most recent ones so that way if you want to send one right now
I might be able to read it. Um, I was never a frequent social media user
I only ever watch youtube vids and twitter for memes and art all that changed when I found you in violor
And now tweeting and interacting more than ever. Maybe in this case it is the exception
But I love how open you are about who you are
I like how intimate you are with your fans not just in a horny way, although admittedly it is a factor
The level of parasocialness is a
A parasocial relationship ness is a lot and a new experience for me on your debut
I knew I recognized your voice
From somewhere but couldn't place my finger on who until you revealed your alt
On your 2.0
I thought it was nice that you managed to attract me twice in short
I enjoy watching you interacting with you because I like seeing you happy and horny and flustered
I'm so happy for your success and that's so many people like you too
I'm willing to share if it makes you happy. Thank you for accepting our freak and I wish the best
I wish you the best little embers. Oh, thank you
Thank you
What kind of other stuff are you told you what kind of other stuff?
um
It's very fun to text slash carry
Oh, it's fun to carry everyone who's ever said the it won't be fun and bad thing have been the most fun to play with
Oh
It feels all conscious
I've sent in a few voice marrows just rambling or talking about pennies fantasies. Do you listen to those if you see them?
I do. I do. I've listened to some yes
absolutely
Amy wear panties for me every time you pull your cute panties up your legs
I am I am wearing them
How would you like a loving oh regarding the gagging on your strap on audio? How would you like?
Loving first for needy. Oh
If you want a bum you can but please don't hurt yourself
um
Needy I like needy be needy. I like we need we need more needy guys
I need I need myself a needy brother
There's not enough needy men out there
50 first dates but finding your but finding your new persona. What do you mean 50 first dates? What's 50 first dates?
So choose especially the part of interacting a lot more on social media
Yeah, I wasn't I wasn't that active on other socials or really at all
um on my pl
I was really busy with school
so like I would just post and then like
Talk in my discord server every once in a while and then just be busy with school
So I couldn't I was kind of not able to be there as much as like
You know I wanted to
But now I can be here
Which makes me happy
50 first states is an old movie. Oh, I see
I see
You want to believe how needy I am right now? Show me
I was wondering if you were planning any games next week and what they might be
You can't wait to see more from you. Oh, fuck. I gotta finish my schedule for next week today. Shit
I actually have nothing planned. You could play games with chat. We won't buy
Okay, well, I definitely want to play poppy playtime again. I want to keep going with that game
Are you going to read the mirrors from you from when you you asked
Uh from when you asked on vacation I can but they were all horn
They were all so
dirt
Um so far the only game I have planned is poppy playtime
Yeah
That's all for now. I'll have to I'll have to think of some other stuff to do
Um talking about school. Can we have a me teaches you biology stream sometime? I love to learn some stuff from love sis. Maybe
I don't know what I would teach you about
I don't remember a lot. I'd have to go back and my um
I'd have to go back and like my uh
My folders and find something to teach you about
You know
I can teach you about animal piss and how pee is made
And stored in the balls. Okay. Um
Um, your return stream is live as I'm writing this and I just want to thrust into your little
I want you so much
I love you too. I want you too
I can't do this on youtube bro
Fuck I hate youtube
Um, here's what I want to do to you and me since we're trying to get you hot and bothered come on
Anatomy
I don't know much anatomy
Um
My biology studies were
Anonymous tip one dollar you want needy. I will give you needy
I want to hug you and hold you close and never let you go
I want my nose to get addicted to your pheromones
I want to sleep with you in bed every night and give you puppy dog eyes for kisses
I
I'm so happy. I don't have my disc display capture on right now. Holy crap. Um
Well, it's in a car first of all the um the link
I think it's in a car. Um
I gotta stop watching this
um
I don't know if I would like to
Do stuff in a car. I feel like a car is really claustrophobic
What's the difference between rafin fish and lubfin fish?
I don't know. Should I look it up?
Most bony fish are rafin oh
You're sitting me a fucking pop quiz on biology right now
These thin fins consist of
webs and skin over flexible spines lubfin fish on the other hand have fins that resemble stump-like appendages
No, don't quiz me right now. Don't quiz me right now
The switch up between marrows is fucking crazy
We can learn together then darling
We can
How about a video about facts of rodents all over the world? Oh, that would be fun a rodent like a rat a rat
Um stream that would be really fun
Stuff in car is really tight and hard to do. Yeah
I feel like it's like this too claustrophobic and small. I need my space
Yeah, car activities are not optimal
Hey, emi new viewer here. I'll be honest
I used to just goon to your twitter stuff and patreon videos
But while you were gonna start watching flaws and find myself enjoying them just as much
Thanks for being your cue horn yourself. Can't wait to actually catch live streams. Oh, thank you
Thank you for actually watching you not watching me
I want to tear I want to tear each other apart. I want my teeth on your skin and your nails digging into
I can't say I can't even say the start to these
I want to lift you up above my head so I can
I can't even say the start of these come on
Okay, okay, okay. Um, I love you my little ginger snap. I'm not ginger
But
I miss you I miss you I miss you I miss you too
You know, I want to cuddle with you in my lap as I am cheering me on and when I get my sicked up
We go celebrate in bed and we go again with every win
I don't want to do that too
The point of doing activities in a car is to do those activities in public while still having some semblance of privacy
You know, I thought I thought I thought I thought you were the one that would struggle to match my freak
But apparently I'm just not freaky enough because I can't do things in public like you want. Holy crap
Hi, Amy. I miss you so much. I miss you so much. I can't wait for your return stream anymore. I'm losing it over here
The social media silence has gone my brain worms working overtime. I told you I wouldn't tweet up until wednesday
I got another picture too
Oh
Yeah, some of you have been some of you have been sending me like gifts
I like gif like gifts of like stuff and I've been I like them
I like getting the gifts because like I was a huge
Oh my god, okay. I was like a huge tumblr corn um consumer
So, um
I they posted a lot of gifts there. So I liked I like gifts
Amy, I love you. I haven't said it enough yet. Obviously. I love you so much. These audios have kept me good company. Good morning
Oh, good morning and good night, especially. Oh, I forgot that I posted those. I'm glad that those helped
Pin pal's winning on the freak. I know right? You found my weakness and it's fucking being just doing shit in public
Yeah, I'm the queen of freaking private but in public spaces you won. Yeah
Did you refine the tumblr gift you were looking for it? No, unfortunately, I did not
At 1704 of your slam girl ASMR you said what a shame augmented
Yandere comforts you ASMR
And then a youtube link
Wait, what's augmented? What do you mean by augmented? Do you just mean you want more comfort ASMR?
This x what a shame until I run out of money or get to the ocean whichever comes first
Come on
Oh my god, daddy
What a shame
He can't really be what is this? There must be something we can do. He was a good man
What a rotten way to die
Well, I will be doing more yandere audio. Yeah, sure
What's dirt x what is that?
Deuce x dirt x
I can't match my freak. She said you're not ready for this. She said
Sorry, or you can't match my freak. Yeah
Those good night slash good morning, audio's got quite a workout while you're gone. Oh
Good game. Oh, it's from a game. Can you do some gas lighting too? Of course. I'm the queen of gas lighting
Um, I hope you got home safe. It's only been two days without you and I already it already feels like forever
I want to hug and kiss your forehead and tell you tell you how good of a job you're doing and how proud I am
Oh, I love you so much. It almost hurts you the best little sister a big brother could ask for
I mean it. I love you sis
I love you too
I want you to rest your thighs on my shoulders and let me
You make such cute noises you'd make the best snack
Oh geez
I mean, I thought I could answer the the the marshmallows here, but I I
Oh
Yeah, someone said I've been working outside all day
It's so hot. I've been sweating so much and I can't get out of my head how I want to bully my little sister by holding
You down and laying my
Okay
I mean I read it earlier
I do kind of like that idea, but I can't read it here. I can't
I can't oh my god
I love that you
Uh
Waterfall it's so unbunny unbelievably hot. I'm glad you like it. It is an incredible
um
Inconvenience to me
Oh
What toothpaste do you use? Oh, that's a good question. So I
Just use whatever I see like I don't I don't I don't use a specific like um brand every single time
I constantly am just
Choosing a random one. Why are you acting so cute anonymous tipped one dollar. Amy's fingers are about to go crazy after stream
We'll see we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll see we'll see
Oh, do you ever share any of the audios we send you to with other girls safer work or nsfw if you do
Are there any that you keep private just for yourself? So
Again sweaty again
Whole fanfics in the maros you can send me fanfics if you want
How do you play near automata? No, I have any any popular video game that you think of and I just
Don't even don't even don't even think that I've ever played it
Like uh any popular video game. I have not played it
You know
Um
No, I don't share any audios with the girls
The most I've ever done was like share
With icy but not not not like not video or audio, but I share like the link
Um and like yeah
Just just to make sure if it doesn't if it looks like it's not um custom, you know
Just to make sure
But but I I've it's I've not really done that a lot. Um, thank you for the five gifted memberships lost
Um
It's so terrible at me since you're getting home today
I thought it would be okay to finally break my vowel solidarity
But I just couldn't stop thinking of you and it felt like betraying my little sis
I ended up not going all the way. No super frustrating
I'm so sorry. I mean I didn't make you hold it. I don't
Why is the image gone?
You didn't have to do it. I mean, I appreciate that you did hold it
And wait for me, but yeah
I see check this track. It's p a m p
I really haven't done that much though. So you really don't have to worry
Um
Oh
You guys are so nice
Hey, it's only Gary loving big
Brother here if you read my last mirror, I'm sorry if I went to tad too far
You never go a tad too far. Don't worry
I have the most unhinged shit in my marrow and nothing has ever gone too far. So don't worry
Oh, yeah, um here this one
I don't know how well you slept last night, but if your sleep was poor, maybe you could try sleeping during your flight
Um, you could take something to help. I used to take sleeping pills
I can never sleep on flights. It's just a thing like it's
it's
So incredibly uncomfortable like maybe if I'm like super sleep deprived
Why are you acting so gay? I'll sleep for like 15 minutes. I find it so crazy that such an adorable voice coming from you
Also came from a flipping spider on your old youtube. I think the little short stack personas. It's you better
I think the spider suits me just as well. I worked very hard on that model
That's a lie. I worked very hard on the art for that model
And I skimped out on the rigging because I was tired
And I had some fucking drawn and rigged five other models before that. So I was like fuck this shit. I'm done
But I haven't proved my rigging since then
It looks a lot better now
Oh my god, maybe I can show you. Oh wait. No, I shouldn't sorry
The model does not belong to you and me
Just because you drew it does not mean you can use it on your stream anytime you want to
It's not your model. Don't steal other people's models. Just because you have them
That's disrespectful. Okay, um
Spider girl was top tier. Yeah, the art was good. I was proud of that art rigging was shit though
I wish I could show you
my other rigging, but uh
It's I can't I shouldn't use other people's models. That's
I shouldn't do that. So I won't I won't do that
Um
I think Amy is very cute. Oh, thank you. I'm definitely afraid of spiders, but I would make an exception for that one
Good you better
I'll make you make an exception
She's gonna be really mad if you show us. No, I don't think I don't think they'll be mad. I just
like
I don't want people to like
Just don't worry about it
um
Yeah
You have no I I have no idea what you're doing to me
I keep I'm getting all these new ideas new fantasies like I can see a whole new side of myself because of you
I was always a dumb, but now I fantasize about getting dressed up in a miniskirt
And a pink tank top as you put a leash on me and me and make me nail in front of you. I want to be your subby fan boy
I want you to be my subby fan boy
Do you want us to super chat or use stream elements? Um, you can do whatever you like
I prefer stream elements because youtube does take a cut of
Like super chats. So yeah
I know you like honest feedback on the ASMR side
So the brush slash fluff effect can be really greeny
Almost like tear or rip in the audio at high volume. Maybe a finer hair brush might fix that
Other than that, you're doing great. I can't wait to hear more ps. We'll miss spider girl, but the new lore is fun
A lot of people really do miss
um, you know the other persona
um
I can't do anything about that. I like this persona. I can't do anything about that though
Uh, maybe in like five years. We'll see
Maybe you'll see spider girl in like six years. I don't know. We'll see
Um, but so I'm guessing that's for uh
Also, I'm not saying I'm leaving in five years, but like I don't know how
This will go. I don't know how long castrani has this doomer mindset of like
Stuff not lasting a long time
So I don't know like
I don't know
How like farsh. I think she said she wants to do like three generations max. I don't know how far
Like she'll go, you know
Link 3 22 tip 10 dollars. I started listening to your past life videos while you were on break
Can I be handcuffed to lilsis?
Yes, of course, of course
Of course you can
But I'll stay here for as long as I can
So gay
Anonymous tipped one dollar. So am I would you ever do a radio of that member stream you did before you left?
I know big bro went a bit too far
I can't do it on youtube
I can't do it on youtube when strawney heard what I did. She was like, holy shit. How is your channel still up?
Because even though I deleted it, uh
YouTube still has access to that. So I really risked my channel by doing
Oh, I really risked my channel. So I'm not gonna do that again
Uh on youtube, sorry, and it's okay. Don't worry. Don't feel bad. Please don't feel bad. It's okay
I'm I'm okay. Just a little bit
Just a little bit sensitive sometimes, but I don't think I'm I don't think I'm that bad
Sometimes, you know, it was a you got me at a weak moment. Okay
Um
Oh my god, my freaking scroller wheel. Okay, there we go
I'm glad you are here at least in it for the long run with us. I am
I think viola could last for some time. I hope it does. I hope it does
strawney a doomer. No way
It's her autism. Please understand. I understand. I understand. Hell. I'm fucking I'm super negative about everything
So like I totally understand like her
You know being worried about longevity like I
I'm I'm I am not an optimistic person and not in like a oh, I don't care. I'm not gonna try kind of way
but in more like a
In more like a well, you know, I don't
I don't see myself reaching like super high, you know, crazy numbers
Like the other girls are really optimistic and even strawney was like I want you to I want to get you guys to 100k subscribers
and in my head, I was like
um
me
100k
Yeah, I don't know
We'll see what happens, you know, I'll I will try
I will
Try
I don't know
I I uh, I don't see
That happening, but you know, I will
I
Fuckin let's go. I don't know
I feel a little bit bad because the other girls are really like optimistic about it. But to me. I'm like
Yeah, sure
We'll see what happens
I'm such a I'm such a doubter
um
Right, so this is some more feedback. I'm guessing it's for the collab with icy
I make my microphone stand is really shit. I'm guessing it's for the collab with icy. Um
Strani did edit that one and she did put her own
triggers I haven't actually listened to the whole thing
I haven't listened to the whole thing. I only listened to a bit of the start and a bit of the end. So, um
I don't I most of the ASMR I have coming up will all be recorded and edited by me
But I can try to if she ever edits another one of mine. Um, I can try to let her know that thank you
11% the way there I
Let's get to 10 mil. Okay. Okay. Now now you're going too far
I
Truly don't think anything genuinely good or amazing will happen in my lifetime. So I get it. Yeah
I'm kind of the same way
I believe in mama. It's not that I don't believe in her. I feel just like
It's more a me thing like
Like I'm not saying like, oh, none of the girls in vealer will ever get to 100k
It's more of a me thing where I'm like, you really think I'll get there
I don't know man
That's fucked up
I'm planning for the worst is certainly useful. I appreciate Icy's working to manifest this shit
And it's going to happen mine says she doesn't let us be negative about ourselves or feel or that's good
I should be more like that
I should be more like that for sure
Strive for it by admire your realistic assessment of that goal. Yeah, like I feel like
I don't want to get my hopes up and then be disappointed. You know, I'm just here
to like
dick around
And like I'll try I'll try like I'm here try to but
I don't want to set unrealistic expectations for myself and then be disappointed, you know
Smallest dream is more intimate better for big bro. I do agree. I do agree
What happened to perfectionist in me perfectionist in me is not um optimistic in me
Just go on vacation for two weeks again, you'll come back to 50k subs. Yeah, here's the thing I
I I've never
I've never
Okay, that's not sure I was gonna say I've never been much of a streamer. I was this I was a
Should I be telling you guys? I was a flesh tuber
Um, and that's when I streamed like a lot. I streamed for like fucking three days a week four hours
Straight that was awful. I wanted to kill my other country, but it was really tiring. Um
But then I stopped and then I realized like I did I did like offline content creation and posted videos and I realized
That I actually like that a lot more
Because while I do have a lot of fun on stream, I'm like so
dead afterwards like I'm so dead tired and exhausted afterwards and um
just working on
Like offline content creation is easier for me because it's like I don't have a schedule
I can just work on it when I feel like it and when I have energy too
and you know it
Is a good way to grow your audience because streaming as fun as as it is and as fun as
You know, I have when I spend time with you
It's not gonna
um
Grow my channel that much really it's the videos I post
And the shorts I post and and you know the other content I post that will actually be
The one that will grow my channel and bring in more viewers
Streaming itself is to just spend time with you
But at the end of the day like I really do have to focus on making offline content too
So that's my vision for it. And that's what I will try to do
As best as I can
But I also know that I was like
I'm here to stream too. So we'll see I don't want to I don't want to tire myself out by doing both too much, you know
Um
Little social battery. Yes for sure. And that's why I feel like
That's why I feel like I uh, I I just do a better job at growing my audience when I'm offline
Because I like, you know, I worked on um videos while I was going a little bit. So yeah
Whatever you're most comfortable with do what you're most comfortable with. Oh, thank you. I want to stream as much as I can too
I'm being such a do-more. I'm sorry
Um, I'll read a few more maros and then yeah
More inspiration gentle or slow
peepee
Gucking you might describe it as guck guckling or nursing
I do like that. I forgot I asked you guys for inspiration to what I should draw. Thank you
Oh someone told me the
Fuck I'm hot shit
Skitzel posting on twitter does great too. Twitter is not the best place to grow for youtube. I literally had to
um
Fuck I'm so hot
I literally had to like
Bride people from twitter to come to youtube. It's uh, it's more just like posting shit on youtube
And also reposting shit for to other platforms and telling them to go to youtube that works very well
Look at me being a social media manager talking as if I know what the fuck i'm doing
Oh
Is this your primary source of income can you rely on streaming to make a living or is this just a side gig for now?
I know i'm hot. Fuck. I'm so hot. Um
That's another thing. That's another thing
So streaming
Like here is not the primary source of income bro. I think strani said she made like 10k this month. Holy shit
I did not make 10k
I did not make 10k. Um
But yeah streaming is very uh
It's patreon wakes makes way more than streaming. Um
And during my pl I only streamed once a week for one or two hours
but streaming in general, um is way less uh
Like good at making money then like youtube even I would get like, uh, I don't know
I don't want people to like get mad at me for sharing numbers
I would get like uh during the the higher moments near the end. I would get like maybe uh a thousand ish from youtube a month
um just from youtube like just from videos and then I would get
A few more thousand from patreon
But that's during my pl. Okay. That's not now. That's not now. Um
But it uh like offline content was always more
um
profitable and that's also why I want to focus on that too
Yup
Remain optimistic. I believe in your growth. It's good to be realistic and check on yourself
It's like giving yourself checkpoints. Yeah, I do want to give myself checkpoints like I want to
Try to get to 20k
Excuse me
Did you make enough? I didn't make enough yet. Yeah. Yeah, I I didn't I'm not sure
if I
Should try applying to an apartment yet
Maybe I'll wait one more month
um
I think I have enough to move
They require first and last month's rent um in canada a lot of the times like upfront when you move
um
Which is a lot
Um
And then I also while I well at the same time as I'm providing first and last month's rent
To a place like while applying like I have to give them the money in my application
I also have to pay for my own rent that same month. So it's a lot
Upfront. Yeah, I don't like canada. That's it really sucks
I feel like the ridiculous amount of sponsorships is what carry streaming outside of the wailing donations. Um true sponsorships. This is a really uh
A big one too. Yeah
Put an apartment fund on throne. We need to fund any better ac
No, I that makes me feel bad. I don't want to do that. No
Oh, yeah, someone gave me the ruined king vehicle uh lore from
league of legends
I do like his lore
I do like his lore. That's that's nice
um someone
talked about having gags in
a lactation room
And me getting pregnant um
I don't want to get pregnant
So yeah
Yeah, yeah, they for real you see what the fuck does that mean?
Oh, yeah, they francaisie
No, probably not
Just put a whole throne on your that just put a whole house on your throne. No
Absolutely not no pregnant only breed exactly
Oh, wow
Hi, Amy. Be careful weirdos hang out in airports us
Sleeping you might be sniffed felt up and pickpocketed
Shameless people do that while you walk through crowds too. I would do these to you
You like when big bro gives you attention your sleep drool is adorable
This is just more exhibitionism
This is this is just some more stuff in public
Okay, well that's kind of hot
No, no, no, no, no, no, no not in the crowded airport. I can't do that. Oh my god
I just want to play with your hair while you draw or read or something. I don't know. Oh, that's cute
I want you to do that too
What about pregonna not
No pregonent no pregonate
No pregonate
You're so cute and you have amazing charm in me
I genuinely believe that once people more people discover you they'll instantly be drawn by your talent
I can see you easily reaching 100k subs. I'm glad people are um
Positive about that. I'm glad at least I'm glad that you guys aren't like, yeah, you're right. You're never getting there
That fucking sucks so much if everyone agreed with me and they were like, yeah, yeah, you're probably right
Would you prefer us to pump rough hard and fast slow but hard?
I think slow but hard is nice
Hard and fast is good too
No
No, Greg
No, Greg Nance. Mm-hmm, pomegranate
There were four of my mellows you at least started reading on stream. I'm the
Don't go too far listen listen don't go too far
I really miss your burps. You sound so cute. Also, you'll get to 100k even if your big bro doesn't want to share you
Okay, if you say so
Um, I missed your deleted member stream, but I saw the aftermath. It was so hot. I wish I was there. Oh, I'm so sorry
I'm so sorry that you missed it. I know people I know some people were disappointed that I I didn't really announce it
I feel like it might have been better that there were less people there. So maybe like
Like maybe no one
You know less less people to report it, you know, um
No, please don't reupload it. I don't give you permission to reupload it. Do not reupload it
There'll be more streams like that in the future. Don't worry. Don't reupload it for now. Please. Thank you
Yeah, you write you you are right though not gonna lie. No
Oh
Pin pals will keep attacking your freak weak points on maros until you're a nugget in public
No, okay. I listen the nugget thing is like not as bad as public stuff, you know
I can handle nugget. I can't handle public stuff
Well, it's tempting to write something so horny you get suspended on youtube
Just for the expressions you make when reading it. I really just want to get a bit vulnerable and say
Thank you for bringing some light and joy in my life
Oh
It means the bestest doing the world is she's the only girl I need in my life and I really do love her a lot
I hope I can repay you and bring some happiness to you in return. Just you being here is enough
Don't carry me around in a sports bag
What the fuck
I
Don't you wish this was a sweetheart
And a twitter link
Let's see what's on this twitter link, please. Let me just mute my audio to make sure
It's nothing with audio
Oh
My god, you guys
Oh my god, it does have audio holy shit that was dangerous. Okay. Okay
I'm so gay
Anonymous tipped six dollars and 90 cents
The fact that you are so embarrassed by public stuff just makes me want to do more to you in public and watch your cute reactions
I guess I won't stop you in a baby carrier. No, that's so fucking cursed
What nugget by the way, he doesn't know
He doesn't know
Just search up what nugget corn is
Amy's so glad to have you back. I really missed you. I saved myself for 14 days. So I'm ready to bust when you give me the order
It's kind of me that's ready to bust when you give me the order
You like the thought of big bros
Training you so that's so cute little sister. You're so gross. I love you even more. I know I am gross
Um
Hi, I mean, I don't like this marrow format for streams between you being unable to read out most of the marrow
Or show us some of or show us the some links and also being constantly interrupted by texas beach
It just feels like a gatekeeperizatsu stream. I know it's not your fault. You came
Scrolling your public replies in the old format was
Oh
I'm sorry. That's why I gave you the that's why I gave you the schedule earlier so that you don't have to stay here
It's okay
I'm sorry. This is the this is the only format I can provide for murals
Yes, of course, I'm comfortable with low levels of love in public like holding hands. Yes, we can hold hands
I know it's a little bit lewd, but we can we can hold hands in public
I know I said I don't like public stuff, but uh, I'll make an exception and hold your hand
We would have nugget in me sitting like patrick star sitting on the bench
What in the wheelchair
Holding hands in public
Oh, yeah, something I didn't want to ask um because someone said I hurt levity like um
And I keep getting like youtube comments to being like, uh, thank you for the video levity guys
Look at my username
It's different this time
Use the current name
Use the current username on the current channel
Look look look at the channel
Look at look at the profile
And please use that name
Please use in me. Thank you
I thought that would be obvious, but I think a lot of people uh
A lot of ASMR watchers aren't vtuber watchers. So maybe they're a little confused and don't know what's going on
um
Yeah, it's okay, but just just just
Don't dead name me
Uh
Reading all these I bet you're squirming aren't you? Why don't you put?
I'm not doing that. I'm not doing that
I want to tease you by pinching and pulling your hair. Please do
Want to be secret club so bad when it's public info what secret club
That is like kind of rude not gonna lie
Dead naming me it's not rude
It's okay
Leave the fan on our ac. Please this heat wave can suck a d. No, it's okay. It's okay
It doesn't bother me that much, but I feel like
It's just weird like like uh, it's just oh weird, you know
They're yeah, they're confused, but they got the spirit. You know, I appreciate the support
They're you're a little confused, but you got the spirit
Amy X Liberty fanfic when oh, yeah, some people wanted me to collab with myself
I cannot
I can't
I can't really collab with myself
Like the only way I can think of doing it
Is just not that cool
Um
Yeah, we hate each other. Fuck that bitch
I would never fucking collab with her. She obviously copies my content my content style
She copies my voice like she copies my art style
She's trying to be me so hard
She copies everything I do
I would never fucking touch Liberty with a my rats are fighting with a 10-foot ball
Um
And you thank you for coming back to us. I felt so empty while you were gone on vacation. Oh every day was dragging an endless
Please god holding over two weeks killed me. I want nothing more
I hope the full passes tonight. We'll see
Okay, I think I'll stop reading mirrors for now because it's been a good amount of time. Um
Yeah, I'll stop reading for now
Yeah word for word bar for bar
She was here first you fraud
No, I'm not copying her
What a copycat exactly
Don't copy strike your channel. Don't copy strike your channel. Please don't copy strike your channel
Don't don't don't don't don't don't don't uh, don't don't don't don't touch her channel
Please please leave that channel alone
That don't touch her channel. Thank you. I I appreciate that. Thank you. Don't touch her. Don't touch Liberty's channel
Thanks for reading the mirrors. Thank you for sending them
I still I still a lot of the ones I read today
I already read myself, but I wanted to read out loud so that like, you know that I read them, you know
Um
Amy is the fraud. No, I'm not the fraud
I'm not the fraud literally every day that I leave that channel up
This is how much I love you every single day. I leave that channel up. I'm fucking risking it because
Well, not the channel, but some of the videos on there should not have been left up by youtube
Some of them have like
You're looking I'm just waiting for youtube to like strike those those videos down
So you're welcome for leaving them up
Um, okay, let me see
Some of them are very blessed. Please don't strike them. Yeah, I'll leave them up
But I'm kind of risking the channel a little bit by leaving them up
I've had them remove remove they gave me a strike once
Because I did like really I did really uh, I did a lot of ear licking in one
Um, so I got one strike on that channel
And I'm planning to do it again on this channel with mimosa
Uh
We'll see what happens. I'll try not to I'll try to I'll see what I can do. I'll see what I can do
I will see what I can do about that. Okay, so
Azir is Azir is live
Sheeby's live selly is live
I'm gonna make a poll
To see who you want to raid because there's too many for me to choose myself and I want you to choose. Okay
Start a poll who who to raid
Sheeby sheeby uh
Azira there's also um
Uh, there's also Shabal Tanya. I I follow her. I don't know if she would be comfortable with me raiding her though
Um, and then silly
So start poll. Oh shit
Thank you for the 50 gifted. Holy crap. Oh my god. Thank you
That's a lot
Holy crap. Thank you so much. I was I truly wasn't expecting to get this much
stuff
This much like support on my return stream, so thank you
Because I was gone for so long. I'm sure some people like kind of forgot
um
Seems like most people are saying Azira
YouTube down bad for thinking you're licking is yabai kind of is yabai
Kind of is a little bit. Eh, I don't blame them
I wish they would let me post it. I'm not gonna lie
Live, uh, YouTube is only going after new stuff as far as we know
Hopefully
Maybe youtube loves you. YouTube does not love me. Uh-uh
I can never forget my little sister. Oh, thank you. That's another reason why I have to post content
Because people will continuously
Leave they will leave and that's okay because I do the same thing
Up ten dollars
Thank you for the ten dollars. I do the same thing with streamers low-key
I wish you wouldn't leave, but I do the same thing. Sometimes I'll just like pop in a stream
I'll thank you for the for the $50 super chat eternity. Sometimes I'll find a streamer and like watch them a lot and then leave
Um, sorry if I ever did that to you. I'm sorry
You're stuck with us till death do us part. I hope so
You're stuck with me. I'm not stuck with you. You're stuck with me
Okay, um
Okay, it's really close between a zero and sheebie, but
Sheebie's the one who won by two percent right now. So I will uh
Choose sheebie for now
Oh, I forgot one more poll
um
Oh wait, that's a Q and a what the fuck
Oh
Shit
Um, how do I
I don't know how to word this
I
I'll just say not no, I don't want to okay there
There we go that should be safe enough for you too
Um
Can I
Because I know a lot of you have been waiting for me
Um, if in doubt use code and dorm my craft terms. Oh
Minecraft terms, I don't know. I don't know how to change it to minecraft
You did get a little needy. I'm really surprised that the yes is so high. I really thought you were gonna say no
Begging got me not blaming you
I try not to leave my main streamers but sometimes I don't have time so it's hard to catch up on vods
That's fair. That's understandable. I won't I won't get mad at you if I see you leave for a long time then come back. It's okay
Yeah, you also took two weeks
Can I village your noise can I
Okay, I'll take that as a yes
Thank you for giving me permission
Thank you, I really thought you were gonna say no
So thank you
You just we just missed you that much. I miss you too
Um, can I get an idea of when you will uh, I think I'm gonna shower first
Because I'm really sweaty um
But after my shower
Um, I will post it onto twitter
Uh, maybe in like
I don't know how many hours
Maybe like two hours. Is that a lot is two hours a lot for you to wait
I'm sorry. I told you I'm uh, I'm a perfectionist
It won't be the chill though. It won't be with the chill though. Um
That that's a little bit later
um, I tried
I tried making it um, but I didn't fill up the
I didn't fill up the mold enough so it wasn't like a complete chill dough. It was like half a chill dough
So
I can't I won't use the chill dough yet
I'm on a missed tips four dollars and 20 cents. Isn't there another poll you needed to do before the end of this dream?
I mean I just did it
I think that I think that uh
I think I think that that notification might have been a little late. Um
Well, I want to do it before the shower
Else you might need two two showers. Oh, well, I do like uh
I do like a mini shower afterwards like I just kind of um
I do do a mini shower afterwards, but I'm not a full shower
But I want to take a shower now because I'm uncomfortable and sweaty and gross
Should ask Dempah for tips on the chill dough
No
Dempah posted an audio of the chill dough and people wanted me to do the same
But I already asked Dempah for permission to copy one of her ASMR ideas
And I feel like such an asshole if I copy another one, you know, I already asked her if I could copy one
I want to recreate her um
Shocking myself with a shock collar ASMR video
I'm gonna recreate that one. So I'm not gonna I'm not gonna steal all her ideas
She's she's got a lot of really good ideas. You guys should go support Dempah here. Let me oops. Did I fail the redirect?
Maybe let me let me let me
I
Can help why am I so bad at youtube how does youtube work?
Let me send you to her channel too because she has a lot of good ideas and she's a really good uh
ASMR streamer too. I think it's mostly on twitch. I believe
So I'll send that too. I will be doing a collab with her soon
I will be doing an ASMR collab with her soon. So that's really exciting
Please look forward to that but the collab with mimosa is coming first
Okay, I keep yapping. Um, will you do it multiple times in the audio? Please say yes
multiple times
um multiple times
I'm already really tired from earlier today
How many is multiple how many do you want?
Says be in lex that's actually really funny you say that because me and mimosa actually do kiss in our audio
Don't worry. We're not we're not uh, we're uh, we kiss you too. We kiss you too. We're not just kissing in front of you
That would be funny
Let it grow rest
As many as you can give us
As many times as you can at three hours
At least six what the fuck is wrong with you the problem is um
Twitter limits how much unless you have like twitter unless you pay for the twitter subscription twitter limits the
amount of
Like the longevity of the video you post
I think it can only be around two minutes long
I think
so
Hold on
twitter audio
um
length
Or sorry video length. Yeah two minutes and 20 seconds is the max you can post to twitter
So I can only really unless you want me to cut it
For every single time I can only really go as many times
As I can in two minutes and 20 seconds
And I'm not fucking paying for x premium
Twitter streaming is a thing. I don't want to do that
So um, no mimosa won't steal you won't steal me from you. Don't worry
Um
I saw people posting two hour long movies on there they might have x premium cut it for every single time
You're trying to kill me man
I think I can
I think I can go twice in two minutes
I think I can make it to twice in in in two minutes can't post multiple
I mean you want so much out of me. I think I could go twice
I'll try my best
Go file then tweet the link. Ah, but that's
Twitter doesn't like links like twitter suppresses every single post I make with the link like I don't want I want people to see it, you know
You know
Hmm you want so much from me. You're so needy
I missed you can send a cat box link. I don't even I don't even know how to use cat box. I don't
I I think I think I I'll I'll just I I don't
I think I'll just go as many times as I can in two minutes
It sounds like I'm cheaping you out, but like um
I don't even I don't last two minutes. I don't
I don't last two minutes
So I'll just okay. I'm done. I can't um
Can we get a mantra? Yeah, sure. I'll try to remember to say that too. Um, okay
But the gifted memberships notification keeps going off
Um, I'm super fucking tired. Is she be even still streaming right now? Okay. She is she is good. Good. Good. Okay
Go support she be in her stream
My cute little quick shock quick quick shock sister fucking hell my cute quick shot little sister
I am
I am a quick shot
Um, okay. Yeah, uh, please go. I think that's all I wanted to say
Okay
Please go support she be um, thank you for joining me during the stream
Uh to every single person that sends me a marshmallow and is like embarrassed and they're like, oh
I'm so sorry if I made you uncomfortable by role playing that I want to have sex with you. It's fine. You're fine
It's okay
You didn't make me uncomfortable
If I was uncomfortable, I wouldn't be here, you know
Uh, thank you for 60k on the collab with kai foo. Holy fucking shit. I didn't expect that to get so popular
I really I really was like
Doubting it because I was like, uh
Cat girl ASMR such an overdone thing
But kai foo's a cat so I was like
Well, I guess we should do cat stuff and then most is a fox
So I was like, let's do fox stuff
Every vtuber I collab with I'm like, oh, you're an animal. Okay. I guess I'll become that animal with you
I guess I'll become that animal. I'm doing fox stuff with mimosa
Uh, actually no denpa's an alien. I'm not doing alien stuff with denpa
Okay, anyways
um
Yeah, thank you for coming
Um, I will see you
Possibly tomorrow depending on how I feel most likely the day after tomorrow. I'm very very excited for uh, sunday
Sunday's gonna be a long longer day. Um
You're both voted so it's to be expected
That's good. Um
What else I think that's everything
Thank you for coming
Let's let's come together later
I'm so happy to be back. Oh fuck. I'm so happy. Um
Yeah, I'll see you in a day
Bye-bye
Love you
I'm so tired
Okay, okay, okay, okay. Bye
Oh, I forgot I forgot
I have the best big brother in the world and he's the only boy I need in my life and I love him a lot